i had something inside of me always
telling me you can't go into
into that conventional path like you're
gonna die
[Music]
and dean thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders it's so nice of
you to give me this time i know you're
very very busy so thank you
very very happy to be with you wonderful
so nadine
you know i've i've done quite a few of
these so far with
really extraordinary people that i'm i'm
inspired by each one
i don't think i came across such a
non-linear career path
as yours from from working with
a leading politician in mongolia to
shaman which you're going to explain to
me what that is
to a classical music in new york and
you know i i can't even wrap my mind
around can you please just give me a
very
somehow a brief intro about what you've
done and
what motivates you in doing these things
yes
um so basically i
i it's there's a danish philosopher
kierkegaard who said that when you look
back at your life
everything makes a lot of sense the only
thing is you have to leave it
forward you know so at least for every
paradox
yeah so for everything i've lived till
now
i can actually give you the logic um i
can give you two
um types of logic one is
very simple uh i've always tried to be
authentic
like i've always tried to hear
what is it to be me right now and to be
aligned with that
you know and so the answers to that
question have led me to different parts
of the world to different types of uh
professions and experiences and
apprenticeships and so on and so what
does it mean being authentic
i i i need to get to the bottom of that
first
yeah um there's so many ways of looking
at it but it's kind of a
it's an instinct that you have inside of
you that when you feel like you're
you're you're being true to yourself um
okay
a feeling that i'm i'm walking the path
that i ought to walk and it's because it
feels right to me and not because
someone else has said
that it's great not because i'm trying
to please someone else
not because i'm trying to um
you know go after some addiction of
power
or money or any kind of success which
are all
external things bottomless pits
which in any case have never made
anybody happy
for more than a few moments so i'm gonna
try to not be after those external
things but that feeling inside when you
feel
you know it's kind of vertical you feel
good you feel inside
yeah that feels right okay you know
nadine this is perfect because i'm i i'm
right at the
the age group where i'm at the
intersection of making career decisions
i'm choosing a major in college or i'm
applying to different units in the idf
or choosing internships and jobs
and we have these external forces i
feel that i'm i'm i'm fortunate to be
able to go on a path that
and my parents are supporting me and
saying whatever you feels right to you
go but i'm seeing
so many people around me that are
struggling with this dissonance
how can it even how can you even expect
people at least my age
to be able to go through that inner path
piece
and not succumb to the other pressures
yeah
it starts with self-awareness it starts
with inner curiosity
you know basically i
started my true true journey uh maybe
let me tell you a few words about my
journey and then i can answer your
question really
so i grew up in business so i grew up in
france
which is such a privilege because you
get exposed to so much culture
and intellect and richness and i was a
pure product of the
french excellence educational system i
went to the
equivalence of the ivy leagues of high
school prep school
business school all of it um
but i had something inside of me always
telling me
you can't go into into that conventional
past like you're gonna die
you know instinct you know it's more an
instinct of knowing what is not you
already that's a good start right
yeah and uh and one day one night i
didn't sleep and it just
like i put everything together and i was
like
yeah i'm going to new york i'm going to
work in publishing because i love
history i also studied history
new york is a free place where you can
discover who you are you can explore
nobody cares hey big shift
right so that was my first one
and then of course then life happens and
it's not exactly what you think
and so that's all but your question is
like
i always believe like you don't do
destiny
you show up you do your homework and
destiny does destiny
you know like you meet certain people in
ways that you can never plan
like you have all those sorts of things
like that that then direct you and i
ended up
meeting on and uh developing with him a
classical music company
which was back then the biggest portal
online for classical music
uh and also a record label um and i was
24.
probably for wait wait so you got you
came to new york to do publishing
yeah and then at 24 my age and then you
came to found the world's most popular
classical music portal online
yeah okay that's what i mean you don't
do destiny you show up
homework you work hard and there are all
those things that you cannot control of
encounters like i met this amazing man
who was also the lawyer for yves saint
laurent you know the fashion designer
and piano
and it was with them that we did that
and so wow
and and i went around the world and i
was exposed to so much and i learned so
much
but in parliament to that i had this
thing about the inner curiosity
like myself better and i started that
journey
in parallel in parallel my work
okay and i so i i was very curious i was
driven by that need and i ended up
meeting a number of teachers you know
like let's call it wisdom schools
you know people who are old souls and
teach you a lot of deep things and
philosophies
and spiritual esoteric traditions i also
ended up in therapy with someone who had
studied with carl jung oh wow
one of the biggest psychologists of all
times and um
was also one of so i'd spent many years
with him
and uh what her her mentor was
calling one of colin's right hands
that's incredible
yeah and then at some point she thought
that i should take on her
legacy i should continue her work so i
was also trained in that
whoa then in parallel to that i
joined a drumming circle where we were
working with shamans from around the
world
and so you're asking what are shamans
those so in every single culture
on earth yeah before the operation of
monotheistic religions for instance
um in each village you know there was
always
a shaman shaman is a word a
tungus word which is a tribe in northern
eastern siberia
okay so every time it's not the word so
it doesn't matter but it was like
someone
who could usually use drum or other
things to go into trance
to go to a different state of
consciousness okay access information
useful for the community
whether or the future or to heal they do
that through an
intensive drumming circle or drumming
ritual
well in almost every tradition a drum is
involved but sometimes
also they take stuff you know like
ayahuasca you may have heard or people
i heard about that yeah you're in
california after all
but anyway so for the record i haven't
tried it but i've heard about it
okay the the point is that with drums
just the sound of drum because it goes
like your heartbeat
it kind of tunes down your left brain
and you can access more your right brain
if you want to put it in those
metaphoric
terms very quickly recap what is the
difference between left and right remind
me
like more intellectual you you tone down
the intellectual side and you can more
the creative
the creative the intuitive you know like
all those other things wonderful
um and that was so you see i had
it was amazing to work with those
shamans from all those different
traditions and native americans siberia
inuits and all this because they still
have a connection to nature to the
elements
to the wisdom of life that very often
have lost
in the western world so it was very
enriching so put
all those things together and all those
currents have formed me you know and at
some point
after six years in new york it felt like
i was done
and the guidance came in a shamanic
journey that to become who i meant to
become
i have to move to mongolia and and i had
never thought in my life i would do that
and it sounded quite insane but i can
i have just i can imagine myself going
to my parents and my girlfriend and
saying
guys you know i've been in palo alto for
a while i i love the startup world
but to be who i really want to be i have
to go to mongolia
yeah exactly and uh a part of me was
saying exactly the same
but then there were so many coincidences
and i it was like just so insane you
know and it felt like yeah i have to do
this and i started doing a lot of
homework and
um i ended up in mongolia thinking i'm
going to be trained in shamanism or
something because that's a place where
those traditions are still very much
there
but two days after my arrival i met this
amazing amazing human being called oyun
who was back then the leading female
politician of the country
who uh was in a coalition they had just
won the parliamentary elections
and gradually i became her right hand so
i was in
government i was seeing how the
government works the parliament that was
working
in the mongolian parliament you were
working in the mongolian parliament
and you met her two days after coming to
mongolia to
to be more equipped with a shaman ritual
exactly so you see that's what i see you
you show up you do your homework i had
done a ton of homework to know so many
people in mongolia but i could have
never planned
to end up having a mongolian soldier
saluting me
every morning and every evening when i
was entering the main building of the
country
you have to come to this to these
experiences open-minded right because
i'm sure that
in the same token that you had these
experiences you could have you could
have missed them
if you weren't open to accepting them
isn't that the case
exactly that's what i'm saying you show
up yeah your homework
and destiny does destiny you know so
you're open
but also you look what feels right what
doesn't feel right i feel it's like a
dialogue between your intuitions
and things that flow in your life you
know the thing what you
calling called the synchronicities you
know when they're weird coincidences and
you're like
wow i should really look in that
direction you know okay so nothing just
just to make sure that i'm i'm following
the track let's recap so paris
and business like business and i really
examined everything great and then we
moved to new york for publishing but you
actually go to create a musical
a classic music portal but then you fall
in love with the shaman ritual so you go
to mongolia to study that
but you actually and somewhere in the
process there you study with
with carl jung's right hand a right hand
person and then you
end up leading with a politician with a
leading female politician
i always loved politics i always i
studied international affairs also
so you know you can't take things
literally shamanism is about accessing
information to transform reality
i want to do it is through politics and
development policy
and i love it so so you know from that
angle
she sent me all over asia to represent
her or mongolia which was hilarious
i spent time in siberia in central asia
no but you know anyway it was just like
um
an education and exposure to a lot of um
a lot of things and um at the same time
it's minus 40 in the winter it's the
coldest capital in the world
and at some point i felt like listen i
can't stay for the rest of my life
you know trying to give everything i
have
to help this country it felt like
something had to move you know and again
i was like but where next no idea
and then in one of the conferences where
oyun had sent me
i met a minister in the tibetan
government in exile
you know the government in exile of the
dalai lama and he
invited me to india uh
to a teaching of the dalai lama and it
just felt right
so it was my next one-way ticket one
suitcase let me go to india
my suitcase yes
and then in india again the guidance and
from one thing to another
i ended up in new delhi the capital
where i did a couple of things i
actually developed my therapy coaching
practice
and i ended up doing amazing amazing
amazing work it was fascinating
within the indian culture within the
indian society
what type of therapy was this well it's
a it's a combination of jungian
right yeah with energy and spiritual
practices
and business leadership strategy stuff
basically
it's one-on-one uh sort of coaching
mentorship therapy that combination
yeah exactly um and i was working with a
lot of fascinating people in politics
and business
design and art and all of this and in
parallel to that
i had uh tv shows on national television
like i was doing a morning show in
interviewing
indian personalities on the meaning of
life in new delhi
yeah i also had a weekly call i was
interviewing every week
another personality on the meaning of
spirituality
which was amazing and super interesting
and i met amazing people like that
and i felt i mean i had i felt very much
at home in india
um i i resonated a lot with the
the the spiritual you you breathe
spirituality you breathe a different
understanding of life which talks to me
a lot
um and it was just an absolutely
fascinating time
so wow and that's a place where i
thought i would always stay but
somehow life guided me differently why
am i not surprised
yeah but i'm in a different phase now
but i'm just giving you
the different apprenticeships i've had
and so i moved to california in 2012.
um and i mostly focus on on my coaching
counseling work
basically i i i call it a joint journey
because it's not coaching or therapy
doesn't
i don't resonate with those words so
much i call it a joint journey because
it's really
a journey with another person you know
it's a that other person
where the toolbox is rich you know it
can be
depth psychology it can be working with
dreams to help you understand what's
going on inside of you
a lot of transgenerational work because
it turns out
we carry so much baggage from the
generations before us
and if we don't understand that we are
controlled by that
and that's not a life well-lived
authentically you know
so transgender work uh combined with the
business stuff or political stuff
or media stuff and all this comes into
my work
i work one-on-one with people and then
with their companies when they own a
company
you know it depends in cases i work with
people in europe
in the us in india wow in asia
and the rest of asia actually in israel
a couple of people
um so i i'm mostly focusing on that
right now and it feels
wonderful it's like the confluence of
all the streams of my life
yeah there was there was some hawaii in
there right if i recall correctly
yes yes um i wanted to make it short so
[Music]
between new york and mongolia all the
synchrony cities were
uh leading me to the big island of
hawaii which is the
which has an active volcano and where i
went you know like
totally like a reset button it was like
a reset button of all my western life
i spent time next to the lava flows it
was extremely powerful what i went
through at a very very deep level and
then it was like okay
how long were you there for less than a
year i was
less than six months even but it was
really really powerful
okay nadine this is just insane i'm so
sad that we have
about four minutes left this is okay
let's you know what let's make it easy
i'm coming now to you
and i'm looking for some free advice and
i i'd love to know you know you've gone
through so many experiences and so many
authentic experiences
i don't want to know how to be
successful i want to know how to be
content
so give me and whoever else would be
interested in this what are what are
some of your earned secrets after these
experiences
of what does it mean to really be
content and be authentic in a very
tangible way
what can people do in the 21st century
when we're guided by all these
technologies and all of these you know
races to be to clean the ladder of
success at 22 years old
how do how can we deal with that
first of all just to ask that question
is already it feels to me like a big
chunk of the work
you know like just to be aware that um
if you just race and race and race
um you know as they often say it's like
putting the ladder
climbing the ladder and then you realize
it's on the wrong wall
um also ask the question and to me one
way one easy way to ask that question
is to imagine you're 99 years old
okay and i ask you uh
what is for you was it a life well lived
and you just imagine was it the life
where i lived and can you just
imagine what would it entail at the age
of 99
for you to tell me yes it was a life
well lived
can we trust people my age to have to
to have that thought
well that's my second point is that the
answer to that will change over time
and that's too fine the point is ask the
question
try to ask the question but ask it again
and again right it's not asking one time
and that
yeah you don't have a definitive answer
no definitive answer
does it my second point keep asking
because it changes
third point and life is a mystery so
third point the answer to what is the
life well lived
is going to be very different inside of
you
if you ask the one who
talks about everything you want to
create or invent as an entrepreneur
everything that you have like that you
want to do for the world like your
impact your meaning for society
that's one type of answer if you ask
side in
in you that's like a child and just
wants to play
if you only work it's never going to be
life really for that side so can we ask
that side too
third if we ask the one in you that
might want to create a family for
instance
a life well-lived the answer has nothing
to do with the guy who's the
entrepreneur inside of you
right hundred percent or if i talk about
the lover inside of you who wants to
have a gorgeous alchemical relationship
with your partner do you think it's
gonna be the same answer as
again the entrepreneur or the child of
the father no
you're just complicating things in the
deen this is too hard
i'm giving it's not hard at all the
point is if you understand
that i'll tell you and that's my my next
point that's where i'm going
that curiosity that was that i was
telling you about at the beginning to
try to understand yourself better
yeah have that curiosity about yourself
now
that's what's going to lead you to
authenticity it's basically can you take
a flashlight and go inside yourself
can you discover those different facets
inside of you because
they have different needs they have
different messages for you
they have different fears you know they
have different
uh modes of operating so i love it
explore that a little bit and maybe
inside of you there's a rebel who
doesn't care about any of that maybe
inside of you there's also a
an inner critic who's also the time
telling you not good enough not good
enough or whatever
there's a hermit who just wants to
explore in the mountains i have no idea
but can we take a flashlight and explore
that because if you do that
you you get to know yourself a little
bit more so by definition it's more
authentic
the life you like i love it i love it no
no 100 100
but i'm but i'm also aware that it has
to be some sort of balance where you
know i i wouldn't
i wouldn't want my future 14 year old
daughter to come to me and say daddy you
know i'm dropping out of i'm dropping
out of ninth grade
because my inner my inner self says that
i should go
and uh and to do something else right
and so i mean i i do
think there should be some balance where
we have a path that can
that and that gives us the tools to be
able to think critically
and be successful in whatever we do and
and you obviously
did a lot of that before you went on to
experience do you think that's valid or
should we also entertain for for much
younger people who feel that way
actually for me though so i've developed
a tool i call the round table of inner
characters
because i found that most people have
about 10 or 12 of those characters all
of us have
okay but at the head of the table even
though it's round meaning it's equal and
i want to make sure i hear from
everyone okay the doer the lover the
caretaker
all of them yep me at the head of the
table
is what i call the wise one okay
the wise one is the one who has a
of a balance has a sense of yeah it's
not about quitting everything and
jumping and taking a one-way ticket and
one suitcase and going to the north pole
you know that has its limitations the
wise one
is going to find the balance between
certain drives
certain intuitions you know certain
ideas
certain instincts and it's gonna that's
the only one that can
actually synthesize all of it and do
something that that is actually not
insane that will help you walk that path
for life well lived so much inspiration
i just
love this talk so much thank you for the
time i have to put you on the spot once
and i know it's not fair but i will i
want you to tell me
three words that you would best describe
yourself
i uh usually i say i'm an explorer
so definitely i'm an explorer that's
that's an easy one
um
a couple of others i have to tell you
now
we can we can do this later but i think
that everybody would like it's just
you know having gone through this all
these experiences i i mean i'm mainly
interested
what type of personality leads people to
do what they do
you know a lot of entrepreneurs are
telling me they're passionate a lot of
a lot of ceos are telling me that
they're empathetic and they're sensitive
to other people they're leaders
a lot of creative people say that
they're artistic
and uh and etc so obviously an explorer
what else what else how else would you
characterize or how else would your
colleagues characterize you
well since i was little i was talking to
people
much much older than me about the
meaning of life
so i've always been philosophers to you
can say a philosopher or priestess or
something like that about the seeker
spiritual side you know spiritual
wanting to go deep really deep as deep
as possible so it's about the wisdom you
know so that's
a very part to me um
and then um yeah the third one i'll tell
you next time
that that's that you know and i think
that it's also amazing how you know i
sometimes i get answers very quickly
as if it's rehearsed and people know it
sometimes
it's very it's very very difficult and i
think that shows a part of it
this inquisitiveness and this not being
willing to settle for a definitive
characteristic
but being constantly in the exploration
and i think having only two out of the
three
is a part of the journey that you're on
to continue exploring and
i'm learning from that yeah because i
think we
truly truly truly are a mystery in so
many ways i love it
and it keeps unfolding i love it nadine
thank you so much
i really appreciate it you're welcome